[Music]
in prepare to vomit news it takes a lot
for me to volley - I tried to be bulimic
once and never think you'd vomit yeah
like you failed at it
fool all my friends were bulimic and
they were yeah that was like a thing in
white girls struggled saying that you
should be bulimic by the way do not be
bulimic it's terrible for you all their
hair fell out yeah and your teeth it was
bad but yeah I wanted to fit in and I
couldn't throw up I could not make
myself throw up I couldn't do it that's
a good thing yeah I could make myself
throw up right now
easily really yeah cuz ever since my
senior year when I didn't know what my
alcohol tolerance was and I had like
alcohol poisoning whenever I drink
sixteen Solo cups halfway filled with
vodka that is not good at all just
drinking I didn't really know what my
tolerance was and then I was throwing up
literally for like eight hours straight
- dry heaving there give me bread -
absorbers kept throwing up so my gag
reflex got so I got so in tune with it
that if I want to if you give me thirty
seconds I could throw up right now so
connected to it that is the most
ridiculous talent I've ever heard in my
life and I can't believe you failed at
being bulimic well I didn't quite fail
because then another way of purging is
by exercising too much so I would
exercise for like four hours a day so it
was like yeah but it's not worth it at
that point no it's not me just do it
right into like a water bottle in there
fine
oh that's why was it they would do this
thing where they just chew it and spit
it out what I like food too much for
that
it's a pleasure until you swallow it
that's what she's submitted by Jo Molly
and sexpert oh that one of our hookers I
guess here are the ten grossest sex acts
as described by urban dictionary I know
one of them - Bill Cosby just kidding I
don't know one of them but I just
invented one in my mind do you think
this would make you throw up because
they have a strong gag reflex let's say
I took a [ __ ] on a plate and then I just
on it to make my own homemade hostess
bar I mean something on a plate in your
mouth
so it's hard for me to grow up but
unless I'm like interacting with it I
could smell your [ __ ] I've okay I don't
know if I can smell it isn't it this
shape like that just doesn't [ __ ]
gross me out
so I think it's just the [ __ ] regardless
of what topping you put on it it's good
and the smell in a splash appeal the
dirty sanchez
yeah well cuz I have to interact with it
I'm good I don't care about the toppings
yeah like I don't care if you put a
[ __ ] Mexican flag on a girl wait to
hear these okay tell me tell me last
night I read this and I gagged so many
times so if you guys don't like gross
things
keep watching sorry or get get a get a
trash can put it next to you just in
case yeah yeah yeah yeah you know you're
too small so you know you want to hear
anyway right so we're gonna start easy
okay okay
they all have titles right so charizard
n' okay that sounds funny okay
Chara is a Pokemon what do they do
[ __ ] light a fire in their ass while
they're [ __ ] ride in the [ __ ] No Oh
what is it when you light a girl's pubes
on fire put it out with your jizz and
flap your arms and say you don't have
enough badges to train me nobody does
like this like there's no way you have
enough time to jizz on your back bro
basically you're just jacking off on
something you know what I thought it was
I thought like let's say a guy does a
girl missionary and then she reaches
around with the lighter and lights his
butt hairs on fire okay next that's what
I need oh sorry this isn't funny hair
shark a Land Shark
that's art so this one's funny they
desire chores it's when the woman braces
herself facing a wall naked hands
against the wall legs spread bent over
so that her ass is lusciously jutting
out I like it the guy is also naked as
well as stiff cocked walks to the
opposite end of the room places his
palms together and raises them above his
head and begins chanting the fame
giving some predetermined signal the guy
Sprint's toward the girl at full speed
with his pelvis out fin protruding and
rams her dead square in the ass
oh he's gonna break his dick in the
break his dick exactly that doesn't even
sound physically possible unless she's
had like a lot of like gauging his dick
when he's about to approach you gotta go
you know what the problem these are it's
like because it's not fun yeah you
better be mad that girl sue me okay so
let's do the next one
no no I told you we're starting easy
okay how about we jump to a middle one
no no sometimes get my style we are
ready to vomit and this is not
vomit-inducing she today was funny this
sounds like a lonely virgin bad yeah
imagining all this [ __ ] like little kids
on 4chan
yeah they're trying their bit okay all
right next one ball kuzey I like the way
it sounds
Finnick you go in a jacuzzi and your
balls float No
so this is when you place your nuts in a
bowl of warm water then have a girl put
a straw into the bowl and blow bubbles
under your balls that sounds dull it
sounds pretty great it's like a
five-year-old game over that it's like I
do kuzey from my bow have a girl put
warm water in her mouth and she garbled
and then I slowly did my nuts intestine
that sounds a better one doesn't make
you got better ones than the [ __ ]
list dude that's a better boy does he
miss tanks before there's a move called
fire and ice where they get an ice-cold
drink yeah and a hot tea and then they
give you a [ __ ] with us it's a song
of fire and ice
we warm it up and then they [ __ ] cool
it down and then they warm it up and
cool it can also do that with
wintergreen gum you just like chew it
yeah well how do you warm it up well
your saliva is warm and then the the
mint is cool I'm talking about icy hot
commitment this one's called the flying
camel it's a vagina somewhere it sounds
like a in a nutburger but let's go ahead
as your gal is laying on her back out
and you are hammering her from your
knees you very carefully move forward
and prop yourself without using your
arms on your dick while it's still
inserted in her vagina you then proceed
to flap your arms and let out a long
shrieking hell much like a flying camel
strictly a classic move wait what I
don't get it boring and maybe life can
ik totally visualize it I can't
visualize it doing that and then letting
go your hands like propping yourself
your dick in her and then some part none
of this is gross it's how it's not even
the camel though this is just this is
just very tiring sex yeah the [ __ ]
ball koozie though I like that I want to
try that now we're gonna just get
started on the group that's to be a
published on to the Kentucky Klondike
bar sounds delicious like poop poop and
go jizz for sure
I love Klondike bars it's the act of
freezing a bowel movement and sexually
penetrating another with the frozen
bowel movement so you freeze a piece of
[ __ ] dildo 14-year old came up with this
Eskimo [ __ ] isn't it mm-hmm
but why is it Kentucky I don't know it's
not even that cold over there I do not
know for freezing though she should have
said like Eskimo dildo yeah that's a
better name for it there brandings off
yeah let's go ahead all right next one
panamanian petting zoo I like some of
these names though when one Force Ones
partner to pick the nuts and corn out of
a bowel movement yeah a partner then
presents the nuts and corn in a cup or
dish one then tosses the nuts and corn
onto the bed where the partner eats them
like a goat or
other typical petting zoo animals that's
so [ __ ] weird [ __ ] you got to eat
corn and nuts first and then pick it out
and put it on there and then have your
partner even I thought it was you find
like a hairy latin lady and you just pet
her back the Panamanian petting zoo miss
Armenia
what's Panamanian as long as I all
you've got to be from Panama like
Central America it's just a hairy
Panamanian lady just a little tiny comb
and just [ __ ] comb do I like that one
is the Alabama hot pocket now this has
three definitions I miss those things
the first one is the art of separating
the vagina lips and taking a [ __ ] inside
bamas [ __ ] up the second one
the Alabama hot pocket is a special
fetish maneuver that roughly involves
taking ash into a woman's vagina
typically followed by a good ol [ __ ]
the term Alabama originated from a
lesser known book additional practice
that involves porky pigging the female
who has received the hot pocket in
Alabama you see good old redneck boys
went forward would [ __ ] Pig at Rose or
large wet piles of mud to properly
perform the porky pigging one must take
a massive chute into the vagina without
spreading the lips this creates a core
that enters the woman and then drag that
explode out all over here by randomly
stabbing with the [ __ ] one will
successfully pour thinking the girl
everything you sound like an infection
it does that causes a UTI for show on
both parties I don't know if anyone ever
does those kind of things I don't think
anyone does it but I do believe [ __ ]
pigs though yeah yeah
so the third definition is a vindictive
procedure where a man wears wearing a
condom uses alignment such as liniment
oh sorry liniment as an icy hot or
bengay type heating rub as a condom
lubricant a hole to give a sexual
partner a nasty painful surprise
owl so just say you want to hurt
somebody yeah that's a vindictive okay
the next one cold lunch there's two
definitions come for sure the simple
sexual act of forcing yourself to throw
up into another
person's mouth usually in the results of
the other person eating it yeah bird
feeder dude it's not warm lunch like
that's real Mormons that's acidic lunch
that's the first average the second
definition when a man kisses and freezes
his piss into the shape of a dick he
then had a shape of a dick you gotta
find a big ice tray first there's a pan
pick ice tray bowls go on Amazon to find
that [ __ ] first he gets really really
gross he then has a woman suck both his
dick and the frozen piss popsicle at the
same time until she event chilly winds
up with a mouthful of piss flush and
pump like this so she holds both like
that so your dicks gotta be small or
that's so gross dude popsicle
definitions I forgot you don't even
create it to be deep throat it's so hard
you regurgitate on your partner's penis
and continue sucking that's happened
yeah I've seen that and the last one is
active vomiting directly into some
chicks head while she's performing
fellatio
why would does that turn people you know
like people are so sexually deprived
that they get crazier and crazier yeah
oh the last one I'm saving worse for
life hmm
next one Kennebunkport surprise secretly
sneak Lee the man fills his mouth too
near bursting with New England clam
chowder then whilst performing
cunnilingus on a woman he simultaneously
punches both of his cheeks that's
blowing the clam chowder if the woman's
vagina but you can't but you can't do
cunnilingus you with the [ __ ] clam
chowder in your mouth that doesn't make
any sense unless you put it in a cheeks
nib maybe like this that's so wack
what woman's gonna like that [ __ ] look
what the [ __ ] aluminum it's a lot of
work to do all this [ __ ] who's the
last one and the worst I want to just
swallow the clown shark is delicious
first yeah and I just knocked out from
the food coma
so this is monkeying or my lungi the
definition says the one thing worse than
genocide one moment
what no shame then he /she must use a
newspaper to find the obituary of a
recently deceased man or woman then must
find a buddy with no shame who will aid
them in this act the partners then go to
the cemetery where they dig up their
victim and flip a coin the loser or
winning depending on how sick you are
applies his or her lips to the genitals
or anus of the corpse while the other
partner proceeds to climb the nearest
tombstone and elbow drop the court
corpses stomach thus forcing out a blend
of rich bodily fluids and embalming
materials ants of the partners
necrophilia it's not even that it's just
like a kid that just said oh what's the
grossest thing I can think of like this
is God yeah that's why these are all in
urban dictionary anything like it
doesn't affect me at all because it's
not relatable like I know you can't dig
up all that dirt or [ __ ] 16 actual
gross things that people really do yeah
that would actually affect and also a
child when they bury bodies they put a
[ __ ] like 5,000 pounds slab on the
thing so you can't even dig it up yeah
yeah yeah so I was some people have
stupid imaginations it's nasty
[Music]